c'est qui ça jack
je cherche le bureau de monsieur howard
johnson du miami times
je travaille pour le times mademoiselle
charlotte blesse par plus pour l'otan il
a ri et moi allons nous marier tout ce
qui a pu être écrit sur il arrive en
water dans la presse ou autre est dans
ces boîtes et nôtres notre regret
cependant ce intime et dans la boîte du
dessous je vous remercie de m'aider à
sortir et l'arrêt de ce trou infernale
ba a organisé pas tout de suite la lune
de miel mais on va se battre contre
cette sentence et la manière dont elle a
été rendue c'est à propos du meurtre du
shérif caunes
si je comprends bien le juge a autorisé
un témoignage basé sur des preuves qu'il
n'a jamais fait
et
ce sont les chemins de fer quoi prendre
les flics ont trouvé le corps du shérif
à 6h du mat
mais ce qui vous incrimine
surtout la façon dont il a été tué ce
n'est pas le seul à avoir une machette
donc
que s'est il passé il est un peu jeune
pour un journaliste
à tout pour sortir son homme de prison
ouais tu n'aimes pas tu en sais rien il
arrivait pas si mauvais je ne suis pas
si fun j'ai une année j'ai vu qu'on fait
sortir il arrive le gouverneur va
gracier
approche
j'étais pas garde on s'en va j'ai pas
présenter de vive dans des bars elle
y est allé de son plein gré qu'est ce
que tu veux que je te dise la force de
l'art
reposent des mains sur moi et ce côté
monique
tu vas payer le prix fort
je sais pour prêter vous les gestes que
tu veux je crois que j'ai vraiment fait
une victime
arrête de me provoquer
ou tu vas journal y a pas d'issue